Republicans are widely trying to ridicule
and discredit, obviously credible Trump impeachment
inquiry witnesses, one of whom is Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander Veneman, who did a fantastic
job yesterday, but this is more than political.
This is very real. This presents a real risk
to the witnesses and their families. We already
talked about Trump considering firing or trying
to fire some impeachment witnesses, but there's
a new report from the wall street journal
which reveals that the U S army has a plan
in place and is ready to at a moment's notice
move Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman
and his family to a secure location for his
safety if he is found to be in danger.
They have been contingency planning for exactly
this reason. We learned that army security
is tracking Veneman and Veneman his family
24 hours a day in case there are threats.
Now it's understandable that they don't want
to provide more details about the specific
security protocols and actions, but it is
very clear that this is no joke. Now, when
I told you sometime ago, we protect whistleblowers
in part because it puts them in danger to
be known. I meant it now. Veneman isn't the
whistle blower. He is a whistleblower whose
identity is publicly known and look at what
is going on. Consider how wretched what's
going on is VIN. Min is testifying because
the president is accused of bribery and extortion
of a foreign country for political gain. And
the person who has to be careful is the witness
because of the president's actions and the
president's, uh, a sailing of, of the witness's
character.
And because of the president's followers,
Trump should be scrutinized, not Veneman here
who is fulfilling his oath, showing up, telling
what he knows. Now there are, Trump has coming
up with stuff like, well, Trump's the president,
meaning he's the commander in chief of the
military. So VIN men is in the wrong for going
against Trump's wishes for reporting on Trump.
Members of the military should ignore orders
that they believe are wrong or illegal. I
was just obeying orders that doesn't work.
And yeah, you might have a problem that needs
to be adjudicated by the code of USM J but
let's reverse this. The issue here is not
Veneman. The president who is the commander
in chief of the armed forces is calling VIN
mins loyalty into question. The commander
in chief is using his surrogates like these
Republicans on the house intelligence committee
to attack Veneman to imply Veneman is maybe
a foreign agent or a spy or has dual loyalty,
a known antisemitic trope which we will deal
with a little bit later.
They are truly the sick ones. Where are the
supporters of the military? Why aren't we
hearing from them against the Trump's attacks
on Veneman we are talking about an active
duty Lieutenant Colonel in the military who
is taking great personal risk because of them.
He's at risk to come in and testify who served
in Iraq was blown up in 2004 thankfully as
he said yesterday, suffered minor injuries
relative to other that were serving with them
at the time and the reason why they're not
supporting the military as they claim to is
because it's always been a show. We have quite
quickly learned that under this immoral president,
anything about supporting the troops is bogus
and we've also learned bigger picture and
this really makes me sad that the military
has always been mere political props for Republicans.
It's never really been about support the troops
because if they did, they wouldn't send them
into harm's way for political reasons. They
would ensure that they actually have the healthcare
that they need. They wouldn't say like Trump
did that. If you have PTSD after serving,
you're simply not strong enough. I mean, these
are really sick things to say. They've always
been political props. I hope now it's becoming
abundantly clear that this has always been
the case. Let's take a quick break.
Follow me on Instagram at David dot Pacman.
Follow the show on Instagram at David Cochran,